and you know that women have been able
to go to buds since 2015 the door has
been open and I think there's only been
one woman who has gotten through to a
certain point where she passed some of
the entrance qualifications because
that's the thing about buds is there is
not going to be a change if you're black
or white if you're Asian if you're
Latino there's not gonna be a change of
your male or female this is the test
this is a qualification if you pass that
qual right on man doors open come on if
you pass I call your female come on
let's do it now if you make it after you
get through that door that's all up to
you and it's a lot tougher for the
entrance exam and it's about pull-ups
too gonna be able to do 30 pull-ups when
you got like 50 pounds and a rucksack on
your back so put a backpack on with 50
pounds and then go do 30 pull-ups that's
a test if you can't pass a test you're
never gonna be a CEO and you know why
it's not because we're saying that you
have to do pull-ups you have to be this
strong we don't want Arnold
Schwarzenegger we don't want the
toughest guy in a world but to do 30
pull-ups with 50 pounds that means you
can climb a caving ladder which is a
ladder about this wide and it's got
metal rungs the metal rungs are like
pencils but you got to be to climb up
and think 50 feet you got a ship in a
middle of the ocean on six foot waves
carrying 50 pounds so can you get up 50
feet on a ladder made of pencils that's
this wide in six foot seas with a boat
slamming around and then climbing up a
ship and once you get up there you're
gonna be in top physical condition
because once you get up there the battle
starts
so the test is 30 pull-ups with 50 pound
backpack on your back if you can't do
that male or female black and white
Latino Asian you know European you're
like me you're a Swede your middle name
is Thor right my middle name is Thor so
if no matter who you are what your name
is what you whatever you got how much
you weigh how tall you are
it doesn't matter can you do 30 pull-ups
with a 50-pound bad guy if you can't
don't even try don't you're not going to
be a seal that's the test and that's why
it doesn't matter
so if you have someone out there who's a
female who passes that first entrance
she's got a little do those pull-ups if
she can't do those pull-ups we'll never
be a CEO it's because that's the mission
it's not because we're trying to
discriminate it's not because we're
trying to do male gender conforming
testing that only a man can do because
they can do pull-ups because we have
better upper body strength so there's
more upper body strength
yeah it helps and there's a lot of women
out there can do a ton of pull-ups but
how many of them want to be a seal so
the numbers are gonna probably always be
really low and so the door is opening
since 2015 only one female has ever even
passed the first test which is only like
eight pull-ups I think so one did eight
pull-ups
it's the seals man we can't we can't
change the qualifications you've got to
climb that ladder you got to get on top
of that ship and six foot seas with
fifty pounds and then do a mission and
that mission might take you six or eight
hours so you can't climb up there and be
totally done and exhausted and go oh my
god
okey I just did thirty pull-ups with
fifty pounds and I'm beat I can't do
anything else I'm done now man now that
now it starts now you got eight hours of
work that's why it takes six months take
six months become a seal that's why that
says one test I can tell you another 20
tests but here's a secret for you want
to hear a secret I do yes please
so I have a reality show that I've
written off and it has day to day all
the executable tasks and training and
challenges to test 30 women so we start
out day one with 30 women and we have
leaderboards and leaderboards be
clicking off and how much they are
because every test every swim every run
we do pull-ups you don't sit ups to do
push-ups you give me paddle boats me
climbing stuff you're gonna be picking
locks and breaking in no never I don't
know I'm just kidding but you'll be
doing you'll be does a really funky
really tough testing and then it'll be
disqualifications people will be
quitting long way
is not easy but 30 women will start and
the only one will finish and then one
female finishes she'll get like $100,000
in a pocket and she'll be qualified as
go to SEAL team training you'd make it
would you want to watch a TV show like
that definitely would want to watch a TV
feel like that you should some of the
tests are really really cool too it's
like mind boggling you'll be like oh my
god but it's not gonna be it's not like
one of those ones we have to eat a whole
bunch of stuff and then you throw up
it's not one of those ones where people
are getting hurt there's nothing in here
that's unsafe I think the insurance to
cover us for insurance it cost like a
thousand bucks because everything is
like super scripted and and like from
stuff that's like tested it's not
dangerous it's just like you just have
to think and and put your mind into it
and also get that you know I'll do all
and go out it you have to show me how to
pronounce that word alligator brain -
crocodile brain but you have to really
dig in it's gonna be tough and that's
gonna be a reality show
I don't watch reality shows cuz I don't
like to backstab me I don't like how
they always turn at his team and team
this I want to get sad cuz it's not real
and so this gave me like the real like
Ranger school SEAL team training this
will be like if you're in force we can't
go into Force Recon it can be teamwork
and leadership and team-building and
helping each other out and kitten 3
today it's gonna be a tough it's gonna
be tough and you're gonna see it's gonna
I think this could be the reality show
that a lot of people that normally don't
like reality and we're gonna watch this
and go you know what it's unlike
everything ever seen and it actually
looks real cuz it's gonna be real you
mentioned the team-building and like the
camaraderie how much of that had what
did you learn from being in the seals
and can you go a little bit deeper into
that part of it
yeah where here's maybe one of the
differences between being a man or women
growing up in America when it starts in
grade school mm-hmm so in grade school
all the boys are playing baseball or
they're playing football even at a very
young age
and so they're starting to understand
teamwork or starting to understand what
position they are and how that position
fits into the the bigger team
it fits the end of the Machine like
you're a cog right here and you're the
quarterback you're doing that now but
hey there's alignment without the good
lime and the quarterback never gets
throw and then all the women are like
they're doing a lot of individual sports
you're not doing quite as many of the
team's for it's now it's it's changed a
lot in the last ten or fifteen years but
when I was growing up if you were you
you were the female in grade school even
and going all the way up into high
school he could be a cheerleader and
that has to do with you know how pretty
you are or how you kick your foot and
it's all individual against the rest of
them to be the best if you want to be in
the play and you want to be an actress
you're up on stage going for that lead
part so it's you individually competing
against everyone else mm-hmm and so
that's gonna be the backstabbing that's
gonna be all the other stuff who's gonna
win it you're gonna be that figure
skater who break someone's leg because
she wanted to be number one and it's all
aimed at for all the female sports for
the most part it's individual skills
pitted against all of your supposed
teammates does that make sense yeah
weird most where in most men's sports
it's actually a team where if you're
failing as an individual you're failing
a team so you try harder to be better to
make the team better to win the whole
team to play your role to help the whole
team work better as a machine and so
automatically men are gonna learn much
better on leadership at an earlier age
and team building and and teamwork at an
earlier age which i think is totally
unfair is that it make it a little bit
of sense oh absolutely
yeah it definitely does I mean that's
just what I've seen from my point of
view now when I went into seals because
I was on a football team because I was
on the lacrosse team because I've done
all these different sports and I've
played a lot of different positions
within these forts I understand what
it's like to be the team captain the
quarterback I also know what it means to
be the the lineman a guard
on defense or offense I know how to I
know how to work all those different
things now there are a lot there's
women's soccer there's there's you know
a lot of other women's sports that but
there's not enough and it didn't it's
not as prevalent it's not pushed as hard
as the men's sport so there's not as
many opportunities for women to be in
these fours with a really learn teamwork
and I really learn that I normally get a
lot of women who are in soccer and are
amazing at a professional Socrates yell
at me but if you really think about it
the breadth of sports for women to
compete and to build that type of
teamwork is about half or less and that
of men you know if you really think
about it honestly yeah it really is and
I think you're right it is changing
quite a bit like as far as Saucer in the
w the WNBA it's changing but I would
love to see more women sports more
opportunities for women to gain that
true teamwork and leadership at a grade
school level which I just don't think
they have the opportunities because it
grade schools when you learn it you know
when you're in like first second through
fifth or sixth grade that's when you
start learning to teamwork and they
don't have the women out there doing
that as much as the boys would yeah no I
totally see we were coming for a coming
from and I see that could be like a
really cool concept for some sort of
programming for a show or whatever you
have planned to kind of develop and
portray those those skills and those
assets that people can build similar to
the seals well in season one it'll be
aimed at seals and Special Forces
Rangers and Marine Force Recon season
two it's gonna be going to a junior high
level and so at a younger level and then
season three it was like if I told you
all of it I can't really tell you
everything but there's a lot of
mix-and-match there's a lot of like age
difference and how it changes over the
years and then they'll also finally it's
going to be women only for the first one
Daniel V a little more co-ed going into
some of the other other areas then you
see some of the differences between
conditioning between strengths and
weaknesses and everything else because
every
strengths and weaknesses until you learn
how to utilize teamwork to make that
person strength add to the team and if
somebody's weaker and something they're
stronger in something else and how do
you balance that and how do you work
that out and so there we saw other
episodes I mean like much greater
team-building exercises
[Laughter]